- I do wanna talk about,
cause we were talking about your show
while we were watching it.
- Yeah.
- I'm actually obsessed
with like, I could watch
like watching Dominoes fall
is so somehow therapeutic...
And like, I love it.
It's like how people like ASMR,
like I love watching that sound.
- Well, there's that in there too.
Sound is so good.
- The sound is awesome.
- So, it's intense.
I will tell you, this is
what I tell everybody.
This show is like camping. It's intense.
(Kelly Clarkson laughs)
- Dad joke.
- Dad jokes. Hello.
- I love it.
- The dads are laughing.
Look at these guys over here.
This guy is great.
(man laughs)
- Wait, sad belly laugh.
Wait, but it's, it's
domino masters, right?
- Yeah. Domino Masters is an
name of the show. March 9th.
It's incredible.
I mean, what I loved about
it is exactly what you said
which is I've watched these
YouTube videos of people
setting up Ru Goldberg machines,
chain reactions dominoes
in your backyard with hot
wheels going through the yards
and all that stuff.
I, I was always obsessed with that.
So when this show kind
of came in my world,
I asked the nine year old
boys who live in my house.
Lindsey's boys, like, have
you heard of this stuff?
And they're like, "Oh, we watch, we watch
domino videos all the time."
And I'm was like, all right,
well, let's have that meeting.
Let's hear about it.
- Yeah.
- And they sold me on it.
And I just love celebrating these people
who have dedicated their
lives to setting up dominoes.
And, and it's enough now for them
that a network is giving them
a TV show and honoring them.
And I wanted to be part of that.